Stars, galaxies, in astral seas above, on cosmic paths we'll trace.
Man over wankity is such a wonder thing.
Behind us all, come see, come take your place.
We're leaving soon for...
Columbus grew an interesting constellation.
According to the data provided, the third planet is in an especially privileged position.
Color is just right for the primeval soup.
Our friends Metro and Mysra dig that soup.
Rather crudely put, I'd say, but quite right, the color seems to indicate the balance of elements, carbon, hydrogen, oxygen, and nitrogen, precisely what is needed for the creation of amino acids, which are, as you know, the origin of all life.
In that case, let's take a closer look.
Oh, with pleasure. It'll be certainly more interesting than this tiresome ship.
No, Pierrot, I don't think we should go there.
The infravision is working. Heat is detected, hence there is life.
The heat could signify volcanoes.
I can't see any sign of volcanic eruption down there. I sense there is life there.
If I'm not mistaken, Lieutenant Piero is commander of the ship.
Okay, let's program a landing on this juicy little planet.
6,000 meters and all is smooth as silk.
Hey, what about a smile, Lieutenant?
No use, she's not trying.
Ready, Lieutenant.
5,000 meters to touchdown.
4,005.
4,000 meters.
Instruments damaged.
Okay, Metro, check it.
We're right, I should have listened to you.
This place is full of volcanoes.
How'd you admit?
Dear, dear, dear, electronic circuits have fused together.
It's a mess, if I do say so.
Pairs are too delicate to be carried out in flight.
Last land.
The piece that hit us was too big to stop.
We did pretty well, all things considered.
But land? Where?
We won't get far this way.
I better notify Omega.
This is Omega Control. Go ahead, Lieutenant.
Emergency report.
We have been hit by a volcanic eruption
while carrying out reconnaissance on third planet to the Columbus group.
Our electronic circuits damaged.
Forced landing.
We'll keep you informed.
Out.
I didn't think we'd make it.
Too bad we couldn't hold out a little longer and get over this barrier.
Out there we could see plateaus and large lakes.
And if there's any life on this planet, that's where it'll be.
You really want to go?
Metro, what's your opinion?
Planet formed out of dense gaseous clouds when its sun was formed 400 billion years ago.
Atmosphere and vegetation of Jurassic type.
Primeval soup brewed over 100 million years ago, sufficient to produce life.
But what life form?
Why don't we trot over and see?
How long will it take to repair our ship?
So three of us, three or four days.
Okay, and if you're alone?
Three or four days.
In that case, wise guy, you can do it alone.
Anyway, you always say you're the best qualified.
And while you're fixing the ship, Psyche and I will explore.
Everybody's working that way.
Naturally, a certain one of us has to do all the work,
and two others enjoy themselves, and it's always the same.
Oh, come on, Metro, do it for us.
You don't know how much we're going to miss you, honestly.
Yeah.
If some animal gobbles you up,
they'll say it's my fault for not being with you.
There's even a little earthquake.
These rocks will crush our ship like a mosquito squash.
If it happens, don't worry.
I have a hunch that in that valley we're going to find enough playmates to last us the rest of our days.
Ooh, it's hot.
There's no other way to get over to the valley.
It's that fault that's kept any life forms from coming over to this side.
Then you agree that there is some form of life on the planet.
Oh, it's very likely.
I don't think I was wrong, though.
When I said we shouldn't come here, we could regret it.
Anyway, now we're blocked.
We'll never know if there's life.
We'd better go back.
No, wait a second.
This tree gives me an idea.
It looks high enough.
It could make a bridge for us to cross.
Of course.
as well try and there's a problem just ask me nothing to it your bridge is here when we get
back otherwise we'll have to fly unless you have another let's go who's going to take it away have
to be pretty strong to lift that be dark soon we don't know the terrain we better stop here
you're right in the morning we'll take a good look jurassic environment hurt pierrot no it's
not serious psyche anyway it was a spectacular way to wake up take off your shirt now what do
we do return to ship certainly not we came here to explore and we're going to explore ouch
This is a charming place, I must say. Let's go back to the ship.
First Allosaurus.
Allosaurus.
Watch him.
Danonychus.
For breakfast. Maybe he'd like a cup of coffee, too.
Let this happen.
Right, let's go.
Isn't working too well?
No, I'm afraid I didn't charge it up before we left the ship. I didn't want to tell you.
Well, you still have your paralyzer.
You call them. You're gonna be a big guy when he grows up.
It's dangerous. He ought to go back to his mother. To his family.
Mikey, our ship!
Do say so myself.
Now what?
I would like to know why this craft has started dancing. What a noise.
Are we being bombarded or what?
...that it is better inside the ship.
I think the circuits ought to work.
Dinosaurs away.
Down in the machine room.
People should hear us.
Maybe he hasn't switched the radio on.
Or he's outside the ship.
Do you want to return?
No, there's no need to worry. He's all right.
We'll try contacting him later.
What's that?
Oh, it's you.
If we stay here long enough,
he'll be a friend with a lot of clout.
We go or not?
Yes, let's head for that body of water we saw when we were in the ship.
Wasn't there before?
Brontosaurus.
He weighs at least 30 tons, Pierrot.
But very nice herbivorous.
the same men were very wise in my opinion to appear on earth a hundred million years after
these nice moving mountains had disappeared you can't just throw rocks at them i really do like
these creatures but i'd prefer we not run into too many allosaurus those beauties weigh 10 tons
apiece and they're rather naughty say a charming place and manners to match megalosaurus don't move
rather eat that one than us it's a stegosaurus nice to visit but i'd hate to live here even for
a visit the shorter the better definitely a bad day for mr megalosaurus maybe i'm imagining things
but I swear he came over to help.
That's what I thought.
We're both crazy.
Bunch of brontosaurus.
It's in the middle.
The adults are protecting them.
I suppose they're off to greener pastures.
You'd need quite a few acres to feed that hungry bunch.
The ocean isn't too far now, okay?
Okay, let's go.
Is it an inland sea or is it a true ocean?
When we flew over there, there were clouds.
Ah!
Tyrannosaurus.
And those are Tylosaurs.
Pretty polite in those days, huh?
And the show goes on.
What do you say we return?
Wait a second.
I'll try again to get in contact with the ship.
Metro, can you hear me? Metro, come in!
Okay, now I'm really worried. Let's go back.
I thought you'd never ask.
We've a long way to go.
We'll have to stop and make camp tonight.
Considering the local customs, spending another night in the open doesn't fill me with joy.
Well, Lieutenant, you satisfied with our mission so far, okay?
We're in the era of the dinosaurs.
No doubt Metro could give us a crash course, all we'd need to know.
I'll tell you one thing, we were lucky.
You know, that's an interesting subject, dinosaurs.
They appeared on the Earth, ruled over it for 30 million years, and then, one day they all disappeared.
They died out. These giant creatures should have been able to survive.
There are several explanations for that.
Lack of food. As you've seen, they need enormous quantities.
Climactic changes. The appearance of glaciers.
But the most probable explanation is a supernova explosion so near that its cosmic radiation killed most of life on the planet.
Statistically, it occurs every 60 million years.
So there were two chances of its happening to the dinosaurs.
Picture the Triton explosion happening near this planet.
I think we'd better get some sleep.
I'll take the first watch.
You sleep.
A little later, I'll wake you up.
Go on, Psyche.
Try to sleep.
No, sleep.
Go away!
Is that noise I heard?
Nothing, it's okay.
Go back to sleep.
Ride about not coming here.
Next time, I'll trust your intuition.
You can go on much longer.
No!
It's our pals, the Brontosaurus.
Something.
At least, apparently, they aren't going to attack us.
Okay, let's go onto the ship.
Again.
Metro, can you read this?
Can you read this?
Out.
Now, and that should do it all repaired.
They say travel is an education, and here I am, stuck inside this boring spaceship,
and they are out there having a good time.
Hey, wait a minute. It's curious. They haven't called yet.
I trust nothing is intruded to mar the pleasure of their visit.
Uh-oh, sizzling circuits. No wonder.
The radio wasn't switched on.
Oh, my goodness. My goodness.
Dear, oh, dear, oh, dear.
Dead.
What I see?
An alasaurus.
Anyway, now we've got the complete set.
Out of here.
It's a great show, only I'd rather miss the last act.
Which is that big?
As usual, strolling about.
Better see to this.
Your paralyzer ray.
Right on us.
Gonna think it over for a while.
Metro, listen.
If you're waiting for the right instant,
this is it believe me it's now or never you hear me one mode of transportation is as good as another
but i'll ask maestro if he can't make this one more comfortable right if this mode of
transportation as you put it isn't satisfactory you're welcome to try another this is my deluxe
service
so wonder come take your place